is this two-factor authentication so
basically to get in
I need my card and then I need a pin and
this is a scrambler pad so basically
every time that you look at that the
numbers in a different order this is the
hydrophone specific facility for the
university with you and what do you use
it for all sorts of things it's
basically to do with the high compute
research so for example students and
researchers will use this for doing
calculations based on things like fluid
dynamics and aerospace genomics all
sorts of things anything which requires
astronomy that's what anything that
requires like I leave them and you've
got earplugs in today for obvious
reasons yes it's a litte bit noisy in
here yes yeah so we will do some talking
outside which can you show us a bit of
it before we go so certainly yes yes the
main HPC facility which we called
Minerva is and then we've got an
extension although he's blinking lights
what's going on is this day track sanity
or processing what's going on they're
both the brighter ones those are
actually the stories of disk storage the
actual compute nodes don't actually
blink very much the ones at the bottom
there that's the network activity we do
shut it down the maitenance once a year
for a day or so
this at the moment is the third
generation of HSBC the first one thought
about eleven years ago and they'll be
regularly these freshness I know so this
one's been going for how long or how
long is this a little ego about four
years okay and then I hate rumors of a
new one on the horizon yes yes we're in
the courage at the moment - and will
that mean this gets ripped out and the
whole new one just gets put in good
question we would like to utilize as
much as possible because although it is
old you know there is still life left in
it and we do try to clean a sweat the
assets as they say but certainly some of
this will be replaced
what's it running would we recognize
only the operating system or any of that
it's yes the most of the Notah are
running a version of Linux and the the
storage is fairly standard but above
that you know PBS's are our main
checking that how many people might be
using this at one time at any one time
they're probably running hundreds of
jobs do they run for a long time may be
running years and we wouldn't have the
jobs that are run for years but
certainly we could have jobs which are
running for months most of the jobs you
know since we'll probably only two days
okay
and so when you look at a system like
this can you put a figure on how much it
costs
capital cost for a system like this
we're probably talking in terms of about
one and a half to two million pounds the
ongoing costs we have about 250
kilowatts of air conditioning we think
when we run this flat out this
particular block here running flat out
point about 70 kilowatts of power and
you're drawing that all the time so to
run this whole facility you're talking
about thousands of pounds just purely in
power costs and then of course they've
got all these the ongoing licensing so
that's a lot of power is there a big red
switch somewhere some master pull to
turn it on yes the Reese and no I'm not
going to press it for you so it seems
obviously a lot of the equipment and
looks like it might be quite complicated
does it ever go horribly wrong does it
ever have big problems generally
speaking it is pretty reliable
individual nodes will fail individual
discs will fail but generally speaking
the equipment itself is relatively
modern attic you think of them is
inherently reliable we probably have
more problems with the air conditioning
than we do with the
so the other thing I was thinking about
when when you look at this it's is this
totally bespoke or is it's like a
template or how does it work in terms of
how do you buy one of these how would
you go and buy a high-performance
computer that's the $64,000 question
basically you have to start to state
what do we need it for because there is
no one generic high performance compute
job different departments different
research different requirements have
different computing apart some are very
very high performance computing you know
it's a lot of number crunching others
it's about manipulating data sazon a
data movement other things about
visualization so you the first thing you
want to do is to say right what what
what is our mix of jobs because the way
which you set it up for high analytics
is a different Hardware set once that
cut for religion ization and things like
that so that's the first thing you've
got to do you've been basically say okay
this is these are the jobs that we want
to run once you've actually got that you
then go up with a supplier to say right
this is what we want to do this is how
much longer you got to spend what can
you give us although this is very old
now you know there is still quite a lot
of life left in here okay it's not
really nice a cutting edge but it'll
still do a lot of the jobs because a lot
of the jobs are purely about run the
country this is perfect for that so
basically we will put the new one in we
will try and keep as much as we can of
the old one so that that we sweat our
assets and that also means that we've
got additionally capacity for our
researchers to use as well
and then basically we will then go for a
graduated placement so as new protesters
come online and as new research projects
come you know the balance of the jobs
will change so that means we may have to
strip out a particular type of note
replace it with a different type of node
but you know so that will be far more
organic in the future we're not
expecting in the future to do a
completely from chef unless something
comes up and oh you know we bought the
new data center that's not on the part
of the equipment itself is fairly
generic you know that these are standard
blade enclosures the storage is standard
storage we have about two hundred and
forty terabytes in this it's all
connected up by a minivan is InfiniBand
at a speed of network this is standard
this is a 40 gigabit InfiniBand gigabit
yes is 40 gigabit yes yeah and also of
course it's also multi part as well so
it's a because you know there's no point
in doing a lot of calculations if you
can't then get the result of those
calculations off so effectively two
types of jobs there are parallel jobs
where you've got a job running on
multiple nodes and then you've got
single no jobs where basic there's
nobody on one node so again with the
with the parallel jobs and the network
connectivity to make sure of it and so
so for a researcher or someone who's a
part of a project what's the big benefit
of doing this world and late in their
office computer do it is it the speed of
computers it the fact that they can set
it off and come back another day or
what's the main benefit yes it's the
capacity because yes and basically the
job will start to run it will then
continue to run and then so for example
Christmas is a very very busy time for
us because a lot of researchers will
start a job going then come back after
Christmas and pick up the data
who say you you could do these things at
home is just that it would take you
months or years to do what this can do
in days or hours yes they are you know
they're all single-phase power but
because the phase on this rack is
different to the phase on this rack
there is the possibility of having a
potential difference of more than 400
volts across the two racks it's unlikely
because each of the rep but please you
know for health and safer and exactly
say why you'll see at the bottom later
because there we use their laser optics
nope that is the fire suppression oh
let's go of a look at that and the fire
suppression system that we have in here
is it's an IP 55 system which is really
basically if there is a fire in here all
of the dashing days used in one go that
replaces got half the atmosphere in here
which takes lots of the level down to
point load at combusted if you've just
about bootable but you wouldn't want to
run analysis in it you know it's like
trying to run at the top of Mount
Everest
so it's suppress the fire without
damaging the kids yes the gas is
released to lose bottles near sprinklers
but they're actually guess just lobbies
yes and how does it work with the
cooling is it going hot one side and out
cold vo this is yes basically we use all
containment so this is the hotter worse
is the cold aisle when we put cold air
in it then goes through the equipment
we'd expect to see a delta T in terms of
2000 degrees the other side basically so
through that glass is going to be 20
degrees warmer are we going okay yeah I
think I'd like to spend my time and
missile yes if you come down here you
can definitely feel the temperature
difference yeah so these aren't compute
nodes and how many computers are in each
one of those
each one of here so in this particular
one you've got 1 2 3 4 8 individual
blades in this blade enclosure here you
want that big red button that's the big
red button that would turn it off enough
no no no that's like a danger danger
presser basically if I press that ok
let's stay away assuming that they are
separate parts of the CPU if we look
back at our instructions here we execute
instruction 1 the users are loading a
complicated point is what we're doing is
by multiplying G by various numbers or
adding it to itself this point addition
we're moving around this curve sort of
seemingly at random